我赚钱没那么复杂啊
学习就可以赚钱
注意
我说的这个学习是自学
你不需要跟谁学
你也不需要跟我学
你自学
就能赚钱
你不需要报什么课
我这条视频就和大家分享
你该怎么自学
你该怎么学习
然后你该怎么赚钱
它是一个完整的心理
然后我想到哪
就说哪
我可以保证
我说的内容是真实的
而且对你16帮助
如果你建政下循定
对你是有帮助的
然后呢
没有打操早
就想到哪
咱就说哪
可能有些
有些时候会有评论
有些时候用
是不是很准确
对吧
有些时候可能
如果说
对吧
你先多做你就
你就花走
对吧
我也不欠你什么的
你嘴下流得
首先我们先说一下
到底该怎么
怎么学习
最好的学习
其实不是什么
西蒙学习
不是什么废面学习
但是我说这两块
很好
最好的学习方法是什么
我说一下我的亲身经济
我曾经有一段时间
认为自己特别的笨
我记得我当时在北达旁庭的时候
就是我要请我的两个
好朋友
就来北京
然后一块学边城
我这个之前的边说过了
可是人家学的半年
人家就出去工作了
一个月当时
你想两千年左右
就一个月八千块钱
我那没人要
你不会问我
为什么没人要吧
对吧
就是我学到很长
一个人时间
就是这个水平就很差
就一直很差
所以有一段时间
我就怀疑自己
是不是笨呢
就智常不行
但是那个时候
就我好像就被洗脑了
对吧
就说
努力
笨脑现在
找入林漫
但是我后来
什么时候开始
真正学会学习
就是有一个小项
然后来找我
问我问我会不会做
其实我之前从来没有做过项目
但是呢
我看那些我觉得
我一个是真的是
我想做点事
另外一个的话
我真的想赚点钱
然后其次的话
我看了看我觉得
虽然我没做过项目
但是我觉得我
我应该能搞定这个事情
我努力能搞定
不是当时能搞定
通过努力能搞定
结果
记得那个项目之后的话
就遇到各种各样
就是在项目中
没有遇到的问题
就你之前没有想到的问题
问题越来越多
但是
好在
我把所有的问题都解决了
然后我突然
惊气的发现
就是我以前
不会学习这个模拼
被智慧了
就是我回来
我会学习了
而且我学的那个东西
马上就能用出来
我学那个东西
真的就是
真的就是学习之用
你知道是怎么回事吗
就是你原来学习
都是老师讲
然后你学什么
老师讲什么
学什么
老师会什么
跟你讲什么
然后你学完那个东西
还不一定能应该
实际工作中
但是如果你开始做一个
像我们的时候
然后你会发现
你试试的
这些问题都是实际中
遇到的问题
然后遇到的问题
就要想办法去解决
然后你再去学
这就保证
什么
你学到那个东西
马上能用出来
而且你用的那个
你学那个东西
在舒服中是
有所用的
所以各位听清楚了
最好的学义方法
不是什么
康奈学义吧
系统学义吧
也不是什么
有时候叫什么
被卖学义吧
你学了半天
知识用的是来
就一个方法能治理
去做一件真正的笑
然后自己给您讲
你现在不会
你给您讲
你能够得着的笑
然后你会发现
这是最好的学义方法
然后我来跟你说
赚钱的事
然后我当时
我其实当时还不知道怎么赚钱
只是那个项目开始赚钱
但是我有一个好习惯
我确实有一个好习惯
我这个人爱学习
爱副盘爱总节
虽然我是中占毕业嘛
对吧
但是我毕业的时候
还是熊熊伯伯的
还是熊熊温让的
对吧
两年
就叫你做人
就发现自己没知识
真是不行
然后也开始努力的学习
然后爱学习
爱级笔记爱
把的整理出来
当时互联网也刚出来
没有别的概念
没有别的想法
自己虚完的东西
那个笔记发出来
大家在网上找
还能找找的
虚完东西发出来
没有多少粉丝
也没有多少人看
年的时候也没有粉丝概念
但是有人就看到你的分享
就找到你
我最开始的第一份工作
就是这么找到了
但是后来
我就开始
比如说我做一个像
做一个像
服务中御的
什么问题
然后我的所思过的
说想就发到晚上
没有多少粉丝
但是有人看到了
就会找你
我当时一片门人的月
都两天就几百
过一天就一千多
但是有一些闭段
可可看到的
就找到我
后来C段的
用户开始越来越多
我可以跟大家讲
我百分之九时的用户
都是我通过
回来的
写东西
然后找不来的
然后另外百分之时
都是我的用户
给我给用户
介绍的
所以各位
我告诉你个方法
第一件事情
一定要去
早个事做
我求你了
我求你们的大厌
好吧
早个事做
哪怕是一个很一小的事
你说我现在很棒
我就钱个肥去做
好吗
然后我想
我想正在销钱
不要去跟别人学
不要去上了所谓的个
你就是想办法
就正在销钱
想近一起办法正在销钱
哪怕你正在销钱
你正在销钱
各位能力有意思吗
然后你会发现
我想想生
也可以做一个
你真正想做的事
如果这个事
别人也特别感兴趣
那就更好了
好了
然后做的时候
讲成一个好习惯
这个好习惯人
什么呢
就是寄诺
就是凡思
每天做的时候
你只要做事
一定会做问题
一定会有总结
把你总结
把你的所想
把你的凡思
就寄了一下
然后你就发布了去
这个你会发现
就会让更多人看到
只要
你会发现一个东西
不是只要你需要的
别人也需要
对吧
你需要的问题
也不是只要你需要的
别人也会遇到
别人就会找到
你的机会
我还就是这么来的
然后还有一个问题
就是你会发现什么
因为你是个普通人
你是个普通人
然后你比方你的很怕
然后你想受
我跟你讲
大部分的胖子
当然不是所有的胖子
他也想受了
他做不到
那你拿你回去
减肥的工作
你去实现这个胖子
是那个胖子
最后你受到的
受到的工作
你一定会有心动
你用了那款产品
你没有在骗人
因为你真的在用这款产品
用完了有真的很好
你就分享给别人
的时候你是在卖东西吗
你不是
你是在分享
所以有些时候
我在这个自媒体面上
有些时候我看了一些
好多一个大分享
当然更多是
因为说是我非常深刻
其他他面我不要冒症
是我会被推演多
有时候我在讲
说的一些值得
很多人在在这个下面
说一些不好的话
我说是真感
直觉独一样
我是直觉独一样
为什么
因为在我的意思里
不是说是我分享个东西
对吧
然后你拒续了
而且还说
张画
我就有时候说
直觉买我说是就是存活
我就不是说
你们很认为
我杀个黄被你们发现了
然后切出来
我毫无定自动
他不是这样的
所以各位你会发现
其实你成本
你真的是在给大家分享好东西
那个真常
真实
那个场景
听英雄不多说
我可以的
所以你在分享东西的时候
思尔人就可以买出来的东西
所以你看我的
出雄力很多
很多书买的很好
因为那些书都是我自己
真正看过的
我真的觉得好
非常可以
那基本说我觉得不好
我就不会杀吗
对吧
我给大家讲了一个
就是每个人
都想成为更好的事情
这是我普通人
这是我想更好的事情
我是怎么打的
我用了什么产品
分享给大家
这个就是很好
还有一个方式的话
就是你在分享的工作
你可能会有一些支持
你会掌握一些经验
对吧
遇到一个什么问题
有什么来经验
遇到一个什么来问题
要有一个什么来的经验
然后有人就会想一起
就叫
然后你可以跟你分享
很多人说
你又是买客的
我告诉你
我来短视频明台
之后我没买客客
但是我告诉你
我没来短视频之前
我是给别人去讲客的
我一场讲客废的
废物是很高的
各位你能听懂
现在我很少就讲客了
你们也不要认为
我只是想照你们钱
为什么
我也不靠这个政策了
我不靠这个政策了
然后还有很多人说
你真正的钱
你会在这儿下联论
我就跟你讲这么一个事情
我虽然不在短视频上
政策
但是我短视频上
就是我发的狗费
就是个流量费
分成
也不少
好吧
我不需要张那个钱
各位你听懂
我再给大家分享什么
就是你去找一个事
找一个真正的一个小事去做
认认认的去做他
这样的话
最后你的事成了
你的经验出来
能力听声了
你就人卖有了
你有东西可别人吃话了
你有自信了
然后同时在做的公众中
然后你会发现什么东西
可以帮助
你可以把这个产品自然
那就分享给别人
就可以帮助大家
你一般的经验分享
出去的时候
你也是在帮助别人
也可以获得像了
收益
而且你可以获得更多的影响力
对吧
这个影响力对你来说
就是就是一个假成
好好思考在那个内容
牵一段时间
我看有个朋友
就是老份了
他不是黑粉
老份在下面留言说
胡思格我见一
不要分分享这么专家
因为你分享
就东西不适合普通人
然后我给他回我说是这样的
无意态啊
交给人怎么学习
交给人怎么成长
通过一边学习
一边成了
方式就能专家
这难道不是最好的方式吗
但是这不是普通人的方式
我从来没有认为普通人能专家
各位普通人专家什么钱
我告诉你的事情
你只有从普通人变得不普通
你才有可能这钱